Ich kann das Konzept des Fahrens nicht
verstehen. Dritte Kritik, das ist der
Titel, und der Punkt ist, dass
offensichtlich eine Erwartung besteht, dass es
klar ist, dass es etwas auf Drive geben muss,
und die dritte Kritik, da
es scheinbar eine scheinbare ist
Verbindung zwischen Teleologie und
Trieb in der dritten Kritik und
dies ist so nicht die Erwartung,
denn Trieb ist eine natürliche Art einer
natürlichen Eigenschaft, die man an
Lebewesen im Allgemeinen denken könnte, und dies wird
dann gewissermaßen durch den
Begriff des ergänzt  spec und
so ist es klar, dass es
in der TI-Logik einige Konzepte zu Drive
gibt, aber tatsächlich wird Schlaf in
der Teleologie überraschenderweise
natürlich nicht erwähnt, außer für den Gebäudebaum, der
bereits in Absatz 81 erwähnt wurde  aber
es gibt zwei Verweise, die sich in die Ästhetik einschleichen können,
der erste ist in Paragraph
41, der Antrieb zur Gesellschaft ist vermutlich
für Menschen natürlich, und der zweite
ist in Paragraph  60 im doktor in der
methodenlehre das energische oder der
trieb zum rechtmäßigen so psychischen vermögen,
so scheint es doch klar zu sein, dass für
kant der trieb in der
dritten kritik überwiegend
praktisch oder moralisch gemeint ist vielleicht sollte ich
trieb und sagen  Es ist verwandt, das ist eine
Sache, auf die wir uns wahrscheinlich einigen würden, dass
die Terminologie überhaupt nicht klar ist,
sicherlich nicht in Kann nicht, aber ich denke auch
nicht in
der vorbewussten rationalen
Psychologie, zum Beispiel vielleicht tut es weh,
um zu verstehen, warum man fährt
Hier scheint nur der Kontext von
Paragraph 41 die Ästhetik zu betrachten, also der
Kontext dort ist die Szenen der kommunistischen
und universellen Kommunizierbarkeit und in
Paragraph 60 seine Menschlichkeit als das
universelle Gefühl von
Teilhabekonzepten und wieder Kommunizierbarkeit und
dies könnte man meinen, dies hat so etwas  ein
praktisches, vielleicht kein moralisches, aber es ist eine
Art praktischer Geschmack hier, aber
vielleicht erklärt das am Ende nicht viel,
also denke ich, mindestens zwei
Fragen  Hier stellen sich viele Fragen, aber
zwei Fragen, die meiner Meinung nach offensichtlich sind, sind
die erste, warum der Antrieb
in der Teleologie nicht erwähnt wird, ja, dass
es einen Grund geben muss, da er so
natürlich ist, und die zweite, was die
praktische oder moralische Bedeutung des Antriebs ist  hier
in der dritten Kritik und was ist ihr
systemischer Platz in der dritten Kritik und
im Folgenden argumentiere ich für zwei Behauptungen,
die erste Behauptung ist, dass es
tatsächlich eine Diskussion über Trieb in der
Teleologie gibt, obwohl nur eine implizite
Diskussion und diese Diskussion
findet im Rahmen der Lehre
vom letzten Ende der Natur statt und meine zweite
Behauptung ist, dass die systemische Verbindung
von Trieb und Teleologie in der
dritten Kritik nicht nur dort, sondern
überwiegend in der dritten Kritik
wider der Geschichtsphilosophie und seiner
Philosophie liegt  Kultur, dies ist der
Umriss meines Vortrags. Ich denke, es ist
wichtig, dies zu berücksichtigen,
um wirklich zu verstehen, warum der Antrieb für die
Gesellschaft so wichtig ist  Kant
sozusagen den historischen Hintergrund
der Doktrin zu berücksichtigen, den Begriff
des Triebes zur Gesellschaft, das
werde ich im ersten Abschnitt tun, im
zweiten Abschnitt habe ich dann versucht,
die Idee dieser Geschichtsphilosophie zu begründen  und
Kultur ist die verbindende Idee von Kants
Verständnis von Antrieb und Zweckmäßigkeit
in der dritten Kritik und dann habe ich
einige abschließende Bemerkungen, also der erste
Abschnitt der Antrieb zur Gesellschaft
nur ein paar Bemerkungen zur Geschichte, er ist der
historische Hintergrund
und ich kann dieses
Papier empfehlen und ich denke, einige von Ihnen haben
dieses Papier gelesen. Dies ist zumindest
mein Eindruck, da Stephanie Boo, die
jetzt in einem Papier aus dem Jahr 2002
alle historischen Hintergründe herausgearbeitet hat, ein
brillantes Papier ist, das sie auch erwähnt  Dass
Baumgarten derjenige ist, der
Trip Feeder eingeführt hat oder
zum ersten Mal erwähnen wollte und Motiv, das
er
hatte  nd all die anderen ist dies wirklich
brillantes brillantes Papier und daher
hier einiges zu diesem Papier, aber
trotzdem nur ein paar Bemerkungen. Ich beginne mit einer
Erinnerung, wenn Sie möchten, an die Religion
von 1794, wo keine
Einstufung vorgenommen werden kann  die drei
ursprünglichen Veranlagungen zum Guten in der
menschlichen Natur, und diese Klassifizierung ist
überall und vielleicht nicht
explizit, aber oft implizit, die
eine ist die Veranlagung
zum Tierischen, die rein physische
Selbstliebe ist, die zweite ist die
Veranlagung zur Menschlichkeit, die das
rationale Selbst ist  Leben und die dritte ist die
Veranlagung zur Persönlichkeit, die
die moralische Dimension abdeckt, also moralischer
Respekt oder Bezug zum Gesetz, ja,
und vielleicht passt das gut zu
Krishna, das gerade vorgestellt wurde, trotzdem ist der
interessante Punkt jetzt, dass es ein
anderes Was gibt, von dem es eine
Unterteilung gibt  die erste Veranlagung,
die die folgende ist,
also die erste Veranlagung, die
das rein Physische ist  Manchmal
sagt sogar mechanische Selbstliebe, die
Selbsterhaltung ist, und sagt Fortpflanzung
durch den Sexualtrieb und dann drittens
Gemeinschaft mit anderen durch den Trieb
zur Gesellschaft. Kant sagt nicht zumindest nicht
ausdrücklich, dass Selbsterhaltung
ein Trieb ist, aber ich denke schon  würde zustimmen,
wenn wir ihn gefragt hätten, ob das ein
Trieb ist, würde er vermutlich ja sagen, also
gibt es drei drei Triebe, die
er hier so klar unterscheidet, dann in
der Urteilskritik und in der
Religion, die Kant für den Trieb hält
Gesellschaft ist eine rein physische und/oder
mechanische Anlage, rein physisch
oder mechanisch, und er sagt im Grunde
dasselbe in der Idee von 17 984,
in die Gesellschaft einzutreten,
dass Satz 4 nur eine natürliche
Neigung ist, sagt er dort jetzt, um wie
gesagt zu  Um etwas Licht in den
unbewussten Gebrauch des Gesellschaftstriebs zu bringen, ist es
wirklich interessant, einen Blick zurück
auf die Geschichte dieser Formel dieses
Begriffs Gesellschaftstrieb in der Psychologie des 17. und 18.
Jahrhunderts zu werfen  und das bedeutet
morgen also ich bin ein spielerischer meide baumgarten
verursacht und ich könnte noch mehr aufzählen aber
das hat eigentlich viel
ausführlicher von stephanie boohoo jetzt so
interessant ist das tomas der
anscheinend der erste war der
philosophie unterrichtet  auf deutsch weiß ich nicht,
ob das wirklich
begründet ist oder war es
historisch oder philosophisch immer schwierig zu sagen, er oder
sie ist der erste, der es weiß, aber sag
es so, wie es aussieht, als wäre er der
erste und so  er scheint der
erste zu sein, der zumindest in der
philosophie diese klassischen begriffe
wie antrieb einführt, also macht morgen
den praktischen gebrauch von antrieb schlaf in
bezug auf willen und mentale kraft im
allgemeinen verwendet er auch gefesselt, so wird das
andere zeichen später
gefesselt  hager gefesselt sogar kann nicht später auf
goldenkoff mentee tut, dass das ist, was
Sie leicht überprüfen können, es ist alles
digitalisiert, also können Sie die Sachen einfach online lesen,
in ein Lightroom zu
Daniela und auch im Haus sogar
jetzt in Lyra zu sitzen was wichtig ist
finde ich zu sehen das nach zwei
tipps von Mazzio nicht auf den grund reduziert werden kann
das finde ich wirklich wichtig und
das stimmt auch damit das er
schon zwei module von liebe sleep
und gesellschaft sleep so unterscheidet  Trieb zur
Liebe und Trieb zur Gesellschaft dies ist auch
interessant, da in der Geschichte des
im Gebrauch getriebenen Begriffs der
Gebrauch eines Begriffs zu haben ist dies wird sehr oft
im Zusammenhang mit dem Trieb zur
Gesellschaft im Zusammenhang mit dem Trieb zur
Liebe diskutiert  Aber ich konzentriere mich hier auf den Antrieb für die
Gesellschaft, das sagt morgen
im Haus, obwohl eine Kandidatenforderung nicht wirklich
schwer fassbar ausgestrahlt wurde, also ist
Gott Zohar voll im Besitz dieser
Entropie mit hoher Nachfrage
, die dort in den unter Erwähnung von Bürgermeisteranzeigen
in dieser Liste enthalten ist  hinken so das ist
komische wortwahl auch im deutschen so das
er darf ich in diese schritte fallen lassen
so das hört sich an als kennst du
sextrieb also nein das ist niemand meint das ist
die standartformel  Für nur sozialen
Antrieb ja, so
formulieren sie es so, aber was wichtig ist, ist
Gott, ja,
Gott hat es so gewollt, also dann zwei Module
und insbesondere sein Schüler, der für sie eifrig ist,
dass der Antrieb zur Gesellschaft natürlich ist
und nicht rationalisiert werden
kann  natürlich von Gott implantiert, ja,
aber es ist natürlich, hängt von Gott ab, aber es
kann nicht rationalisiert werden, das ist
wirklich wichtig, wir würden die gleiche
Geschichte in Baumgarten
finden  Der Antrieb zur
Gesellschaft in Baumgarten ist also auch
nicht rational, rein natürlich und sogar
mechanisch. Ein weiterer interessanter
[Musik]
-Hintergrund hier, der leider
bereits von den Vorrednern erwähnt wurde, ist
kuzey  Seine Unklugheit in
Paragraph 122 besagt, dass der Antrieb zur
Gesellschaft einer der grundlegenden
Antriebe ist, und das Zitat fällt auf einen
Kunstgriff und eine Anpassung  n der
Reaktandeninvasion durch fallende gemeinsame Höhe durch
Neiman, also klingt dies wieder seltsam
objektiv, was er damit meint,
natürlich ist der Mensch so ein Objekt, das
perfekt ist oder das dem
Subjekt seine kognitiven
Fähigkeiten für einige moralische
Fähigkeiten perfekt entwickeln kann  Der Mensch dort ist auch
wichtig, weil Khan
gewisse Hinweise auf diese Ansicht von gemütlichen
O's zu machen scheint, ohne später zu erwähnen, also könnte ich fortfahren, aber ich
empfehle Ihnen nur, diesen Artikel von Bucha jetzt zu lesen,
da sie alle
Details zu allen Quellen gibt  aber was
wirklich wichtig ist, ist zu sehen, dass dies
ein natürlicher Antrieb ist, es kann nicht
rationalisiert werden und es stammt von Gott, es
hängt von Gott ab, dass dies der Fall ist, und
morgen scheint der Schlaf eingeführt
oder zum ersten Mal verwendet worden zu sein, und
dies ist auch der Fall  der fall in rüdiger bom bom
garden volve kuja's und so weiter, aber ich
sollte sagen, dass dies natürlich nur
eine art ist, diesen hintergrund zu buchstabieren, an den ich
mich auch hätte wenden können
Diese Hintergrundgeschichte, obwohl dies
nicht geklappt hätte. Ich denke, dies ist nur
meine Behauptung, und es würde einige
Zeit dauern, dies zu zeigen, aber ein einfacher Grund
ist, dass sie kein Laufwerk verwenden. Sie werden dort kein
Laufwerk finden, aber ich habe es nicht getan  finden Sie
es, was Sie wollen und so weiter, das finden Sie
in bewährten DAF-Lebensmittelgeschäften.
Hopfenbeweis genug.
Shaftesbury Hutchison, Sie könnten hinzufügen, dass eine
böse Seele hierher gehört, also
wäre es sowieso eine ganz andere Geschichte,
dies vor dem Hintergrund zu erzählen
Davon dann mein zweiter Abschnitt hier in
meinem Vortrag, der der Hauptabschnitt ist, so
dass es offensichtlich eine Verbindung
zwischen dem Streben nach Gesellschaft und der
Zweckmäßigkeit gibt, und die
Frage ist nun, wie diese Verbindung argumentiert werden kann
und was bedeutet dieser link
eigentlich oh das der begriff trieb zur
gesellschaft bedeutet und nicht so wenn wir uns nochmal
die idee anschauen
satz 4 besteht der
mensch hat eine neigung also sagt er
neigung ok also ich denke
er ist nicht ganz klar ab  Aus der
Terminologie hier also Neigung
zur Vergesellschaftung heraus, da er sich in einem solchen
Zustand mehr als
Mensch fühlt, dh die Entwicklung
seiner natürlichen Veranlagungen spürt, so ist hier
schon 1784 wieder der Trieb zur Gesellschaft der Neigung natürlich
wieder genauso inne  die
Urteilskritik die dritte Kritik
Absatz 41 Absatz 60 die natürlichen
Triebe bzw. der Trieb zur Gesellschaft und
Geselligkeit ist ein natürlicher Trieb nun ich
glaube Kant hat jetzt wirklich ein ganz bestimmtes
Argument im Sinn um zu zeigen
warum das so ist und welche
Folgen das hat  dies hat und was ich
jetzt im nächsten auf den nächsten paar
Folien tun werde, ist, dieses Argument zu rekonstruieren,
und wir müssten von den
ersten drei Sätzen der Idee
1784 ausgehen, wo Krebs so nach der
teleologischen Naturlehre und
dort sagt er  einfach mal voraussetzen
es ist ziemlich gestellt er sagt
nichts mehr er erwähnt nicht woher
er es hat was es bedeutet was
auch interessiert ist  Der Haken an der Sache ist, dass er
dieses Zeug anscheinend von der
Idee in die Kritik des Urteils kopiert hat,
weil sie buchstäblich dasselbe sind, was
sie wörtlich in Paragraph 81,
82 und 83 sagen sollen, wie wir sowieso sehen werden,
also ist das eine Voraussetzung der teleologischen
Doktrin  der Natur oder natürlichen
Veranlagungen eines Lebewesens und
bestimmt einige Zeit,
sich vollständig und zielgerichtet zu entwickeln,
wichtig ist nun, dass er
dies im Sinne von
Entwicklung auffasst und nicht nur, dass er
betont, dass diese vollständige
Entwicklung nur
in der Art liegt, sondern  nicht im Einzelnen
und diese höchsten wirklich grundlegenden
Konsequenzen oder es ist zumindest ein
Hinweis darauf, wie Kant denkt, wie unsere
kognitiven Fähigkeiten aussehen und
was wir seiner Meinung nach damit tun können und was
nicht, wenn Sie nur an die Bussard-
Oh-Pädagogik denken, die er er  unterstützt, dass
es sehr dafür ist, da
Basel das erste war, das eine Art
alternative Art von Pädagogik und
Erziehungsform präsentierte  ung Erwachsene oder Kinder
, um von dieser Art von Frömmigkeit wegzukommen, bleiben Sie
vorsichtig bei strenger Bildung und entwickeln Sie einen
freien Weg oder ermöglichen Sie eine freie
Entwicklung kognitiver kognitiver
Fähigkeiten und so weiter. Ich erwähne
dies nur und das ist meiner Meinung nach etwas  der
hintergrund hier, also das bild ist, dann
brauchen wir entwicklung kognitive kapazitäten
kapazitäten im allgemeinen müssen sich entwickeln
und wir können nicht einfach mit
etwas vorgeformtem anfangen und dann einfach warten,
bis es wächst, also spezies und das
individuelle und dann und die frage ist,
ob das so ist  ist der Fall, wenn es eine Entwicklung gibt,
wie
muss diese Entwicklung aussehen, und
er sagt dann gut, welche Mittel die Natur
einsetzt, weil die Natur
hier die Arbeit macht, die Mittel, die die Natur
einsetzt, um die
Entwicklung aller ihrer zu bewirken  Veranlagungen
sind der Antagonismus in der Gesellschaft. Dies
kommt in verschiedenen Zitaten gut zum Ausdruck, in denen Kant
sagt, dass Dinge wie die Natur es gewollt haben
und die Dinge der Natur für sozialen
Betrug gehören  Konflikte und sogar Kriege,
sagt er, dass auch in der Metaphysik der
Moral später, wie wir wissen, warum gut
zitieren aus dem Ideensatz für, denn
ohne sie würden all die hervorragenden natürlichen
De-Anlagen und die Menschheit
nur Schlummer essen würden, unentwickelt, der
Mensch wird aber die Natur erobern
besser weiß, was gut für die Art ist, nicht
für das Individuum, für die Art, die
es missachten wird, so eindeutig
ist dann der natürliche Trieb zur Gesellschaft die Ursache für die
soziale Entwicklung und wie wir später sehen werden,
auch für andere Dinge der Verlauf
und die Bedingung der Entwicklung  der
natürlichen Dispositionen scheint
also schon in der Idee Teleologie des
Triebes mit Dingen am Werk zu sein und
natürlich muss er dann natürlich
etwas ausführlicher über den Plan der Natur sagen, also den Plan der
Natur, nämlich den sozialen Zustand zustande zu bringen, zu
fördern  der
menschlichen Entwicklung, unter der die
vollständige Entfaltung der
Anlagen stattfinden kann, die
Triebteleologie aber nur  angespielt in
wirklich in der idee und ich denke, es
hat viel viel glück gemacht, es in der dritten kritik zurück zu jagen,
und dem werde ich mich
jetzt zuwenden, also das ist die dritte kritik, die
dann hat oder wieder mit
der teleologischen entwicklung der geschichte beginnt
Wegen des
Plans der Natur muss die Geschichte einen Plan haben, unsere Natur muss einen
Plan haben in Bezug auf die historische
Entwicklung,
also nur ein paar Worte darüber, was Kant denkt, dass
Geschichtsphilosophie dann
mit der Teleologie zu tun hat, weil
es irgendwie überraschend ist, wie das so ist
Geschichtsphilosophie passt hier hinein. Ich
denke, das ist keine Mentor-Plünderung, und
Sie können mir später in den Fragen und Antworten
mitteilen, ob Sie denken, dass dies zu viel
oder vielleicht nicht genug ist, obwohl es in
der Geschichtsphilosophie für Kant darum geht
, kausale Zusammenhänge zwischen
Handlungen zu verstehen  denn wenn man anfängt den
gedanken zu lesen sagt er ja schon das ihre
erscheinen handlungen reine folge sind und
ihre erscheinen dem freien willen folgen und
dann alles über die geschichte gehen soll
dann und das ist meine Formulierung davon,
als organisches Ganzes gedacht werden
, um es zu ermöglichen, dann das
Prinzip des reflektierenden Urteils anzuwenden, also
objektive Zweckmäßigkeit, was bedeutet das
so und warum ist dies erforderlich dies
ist erforderlich, wie bereits in dem gesagt
Idee, weil Geschichte nicht
als eine Anhäufung von Handlungen verstanden werden sollte,
es ist keine Anhäufung, es ist keine
Addition von Handlungen, Geschichte ist in diesem Sinne,
und ich leihe mir das aus der betrachteten
radikalen Philosophie, ist kein Komposit oder
ein Allah, etwas, das einfach
zusammengefügt wird und  kann ein hübscher Teil sein, es ist
kein Komposit oder ein Allah, aber Geschichte wird
als Komposit oder EDR als organisches
Ganzes betrachtet, was einfach bedeutet, dass es
als Ganzes vorausgesetzt werden muss, um dann
die Handlungen darin jetzt zu platzieren oder zu lokalisieren,
und das ist gerecht  analog dazu, dass der
begriff die idee eines organisierten
wesens so in die teleologie hineinkommt,
stellt sich natürlich die frage, wenn das
das ende ist, hat die geschichte
ein en  d und auf eine überraschende Weise
besteht es darin, dass Sie vielleicht sogar wissen, dass er
niemals sagen würde, nein, ja, er sagt
etwas in dieser Richtung, ja,
das Ende ist die vollständige und zielgerichtete
Entwicklung aller natürlichen Anlagen.
Nun, wie wird diese Entwicklung
ermöglicht?  Natürlich der
Drang zur Gesellschaft, die
jetzt konkreter die Zivilgesellschaft ist, also eine Rechtsgesellschaft
, und ich habe das eingeklammert,
weil er dies natürlich
auf die Union der Zivilgesellschaften auf
der kosmopolitischen Ebene ausdehnt. Ja, aber das belasse ich nicht
dass ich dies belassen
und nicht näher darauf eingehen werde, also ist der
rechtmäßige Internationale
Staatenbund Kant derjenige, der das
Konzept des Föderalismus einführt,
was vor dem Föderalismus nicht verwendet wurde, was er
jetzt im Sinn hat, denke ich  kann wirklich
in seiner Lehre vom endgültigen Ende in
Absatz 81 gesehen werden, kann Gebäude nicht erwähnen,
schlafen, er diskutiert es nicht einmal, aber okay,
er hat es irgendwie umschrieben, sagte und
dann lässt er es beiseite, er d  o erwähnt es nicht noch
einmal
in Absatz 82 83, wo er
die Doktrin des Ultimativen darlegt, und sie verwendet
auch keinen Tweet, aber
es ist klar, dass er hat, dass er genau das
im Sinn hat, also sagt er
in Absatz  82 dass es
überraschenderweise jetzt nicht nur innere oder
unmittelbare zweckbestimmung gibt
sondern dass es äussere zweckbestimmung gibt
das ist bekannte äussere zweckbestimmung
was bedeutet das
dass als definition dient das eine in der natur
und das andere als mittel zum
zweck okay also
akzeptiere das einfach für die  Der
Argumentation halber ja, wenn wir es akzeptieren, dann sieht es so aus, als würde
Kant argumentieren, dass wir ein System
des natürlichen Endes haben, das quasi
aristotelisch erfordert, was ein Finale erfordert,
und hier geht es nicht darum, dass wir arbeiten,
also das ultimative Ende, hier geht es jetzt darum, dies
ist die Referenz  bis zur Endspezifikation, aber
das ist hier nicht das Thema. Khan sagt,
ja, also noch nicht, was ich in die
Hände bekommen muss, ist die Bedeutung des endgültigen Endes,
warum gut, weil das endgültige Ende
eindeutig jenseits der Natur liegt  und das
interessiert mich gerade nicht ich
interessiere mich nur für das letztendliche ziel,
das in der natur liegt,
jetzt wieder überraschende konzepte, was
das letztendliche ziel in der natur für den
menschen ist, warum ist das so gut, weil
der mensch  Er denkt, dass es das einzige
Wesen ist, das das Potenzial hat, Ziele zu setzen
und die Mittel für Zwecke zu wählen.
Es gibt keine anderen Wesen in der Natur
, die dieses Potenzial haben, und Sie
wissen es vielleicht nicht, aber es gibt diese Experimente
mit seinen und so weiter und so weiter, okay  Ja,
aber auf einer höheren Ebene, denke ich, könnten wir der
Zählung zustimmen, wenn wir das auch akzeptieren,
dann ist im nächsten Schritt, dass die
Beziehung zwischen organisierten Wesen in der
Natur zweckgerichtet ist, also bezieht sich dies nur auf eine
externe Zweckmäßigkeit aus einer externen Perspektive
aber das ist und nur um Sie daran zu erinnern,
nicht objektiv so, aber das ist nur so
für die menschliche Spezies, also für das reflektierende
Urteil ist dies nur so natürlich für das
reflektierende Urteil, jetzt ist der entscheidende
Punkt, dass con  Ich bin
überzeugt, dass wir
jetzt die Beziehung zwischen dem
Menschen, der das
Letzte ist, und der Natur und der Natur selbst bestimmen müssen
, und jetzt
schlägt Country ein Argument vor, das
von a ausgeht  Disjunktion sind seiner Meinung nach die einzigen
zwei Kandidaten, die
diese Frage wirklich beantworten oder formulieren und bestimmen könnten,
was diese Beziehung ist, und der
erste ist die erste Option, die wir wirklich
haben, dass die Natur als Mittel dient und
Glück fördert, aber Freundlichkeit und -
Sie nur die Menschen  Ich könnte einfach
die Natur erkunden und indem wir sie erforschen,
tun wir das gerade.
Ich denke, die
Diskussion, die gerade stattfindet, ist nur das Ziel
des Glücks. Ja, die Natur dient dem
Glück des einzelnen Menschen oder der menschlichen Spezies, und das ist
jetzt entscheidend  Die zweite Option, die wir haben, ist, dass die
Natur als die
Fähigkeit und Fähigkeit für alle möglichen Zwecke aufzufassen
ist, und das ist jetzt die Kultur, warum denkt er das
?  s ist dies John könnten wir nur
wissen, gehen Sie für Glück
nein, weil Glück das Letzte und
in gerechter materieller Hinsicht ist und dies
wiederum wissen wir aus der Grundlegung
bereits und aus anderen Schriften Kant ist nicht
so sehr für Glück als für ein moralisches
Prinzip und so  weiter und so weiter, wenn er
hier in diesem Zusammenhang ähnliche Argumente
vorbringt, aber wichtiger ist, dass es ein
Material ist, und die Alternative wäre
dann das Formale, und so haben wir genau
dieses disjunkte formale und materielle
Material, das nicht funktioniert, also muss es
früher sein  der formale und doch
letzte zweck der natur als formaler zweck
ist die herstellung der fähigkeit eines
vernünftigen wesens für jeden und überhaupt
also seiner freiheit sagt er und das ist
wie gesagt kultur wie bewußte
kultur warum ist das so  denn ja
kultur bedeutet einfach wenn ich nicht kann dass der
mensch die natürlichen mittel herstellt die
er oder sie braucht um seine
oder ihre ziele zu erreichen und das ist
grundlegend anders als nur
die natur zu erforschen wir können  Erforsche es einfach
und das ist in Ordnung, sei nicht glücklich, das
funktioniert nicht,
ein ultimatives Ende kann nur eine formale,
ultimative Anzeige sein, also erfordert diese Fähigkeit und das
Produzieren von Mitteln, nur einen
Vorschlag zu erinnern, denn aus der Ideenentwicklung ist
dies nicht einfach da, ja,
wir werden nicht geboren  mit diesen Fähigkeiten
mit diesen Fähigkeiten müssen wir sie
entwickeln wir müssen erzogen werden
, um sie im Laufe
der Geschichte auf der Ebene der Spezies vollständig zu entwickeln, so dass die
Fähigkeit zur Produktion von Mitteln die
Entwicklung natürlicher Anlagen im
Laufe der Geschichte der menschlichen
Spezies erfordert  und Sie könnten jetzt denken
, das ist das Ende der Geschichte, die
Argumentation ist wirklich kompliziert, denke ich,
und ich habe bereits viele Dinge ausgelassen,
viele Details, aber ich hoffe, es ist zumindest
klar, wie die Grundstruktur oder
so ist  das ist noch nicht das
Ende und du denkst vielleicht, oh, jetzt haben wir
es, es ist die Form als Kultur, jetzt, wo der
Punkt jetzt ist, dass
es uns nicht sehr formal machen würde, was wir brauchen, ist j  Nur
die Idee, dass Entwicklung
nur durch Ungleichheit unter den
Bürgern oder Menschen möglich ist, das ist genau die
Idee der sozialen Triebe des Strebens
nach Gesellschaft, die Konflikte
schafft  und das hat
mittelfristig oder sogar langfristig oder sogar kurzfristig das
Ergebnis grundlegender Meinungsverschiedenheiten, Sie
kennen Kriegskämpfe und so weiter, und all dies
trägt dazu bei, dass die Unähnlichkeit
individueller Konfliktfähigkeiten
Konflikte verursacht, und diese natürlichen
Konflikte fördern den Fortschritt von
Mut
und dann  die einstige Bedingung für diese
vollständige Entfaltung der Naturanlage ist
dann die bürgerliche Gesellschaft
und jetzt ist er über die Lehre vom
Letzten und er kommt auf das zurück, was er
bereits 1780 84 gesagt hat, ja obwohl er
innerhalb der
Teleologie so die Mittel der Natur viel expliziter gemacht hat  dann die
Verwirklichung der Zivilgesellschaft und das ist immer das,
was seither dem kosmopolitischen Ganzen hinzugefügt werden muss
ist genau die gleiche
Geschichte, die in der Lehre von
den Fakultäten in der Metaphysik der
Moral und im virtuellen Frieden
usw. erzählt wird. Das Mittel der Natur, die Gesellschaft zu verwirklichen, ist
dann wieder der Trieb zur Gesellschaft plus
Antagonismus, das ist das Argument, und
das ist meine abschließende Bemerkung  nur ein
paar wieder, also haben wir den trieb zur gesellschaft
als eine rein natürliche veranlagung,
von wo aus ich angefangen habe, es ist eindeutig so,
dass es nicht gott ist, sondern die natur, die
es so will, und das ist, denke ich,
wirklich gegen diese tradition von tomas gerichtet
Regeln und anderen in der Idee geht
er davon aus, dass die vollständige
Entwicklung der Dispositionen der
natürlichen Dispositionen eine Art
analytische Wahrheit ist, wenn es eine Chiliologie
der Natur gibt und wenn es natürliche
Dispositionen gibt, dann müssen diese natürlichen
Dispositionen
ganz anders entwickelt werden  das wäre
widersprüchlich wer diese
entwicklung
wohl fördert der trieb zur gesellschaft der trieb zur
gesellschaft und der gesellschaftliche zustand schließlich
und wieder die rechtmäßige
Zivilgesellschaft als Plan der Natur, vielleicht
sollte man sich hier nicht entgehen lassen, also
behauptet er nicht, dass die Natur hier ein
handelnder Faktor ist, wie es sich anhört, aber
das ist nicht das, was er sagt,
es ist keine Hypothese einer Sünde der
Natur  Als solches können wir vielleicht
in der Diskussion darauf zurückkommen, also bedeutet die
Natur genau, dass diese diesen
Konfliktantagonismus getan haben, der Kultur schafft,
und von dort aus können wir zu einem
vollwertigen Modell übergehen, würde ich sagen und ich denke,
was Kant  im Sinn hat, ist dieser Antrieb zur
Gesellschaft, man könnte es Modell nennen,
das als nicht-zeitlich zu verstehen ist, ja, also ist
es natürlich eine nicht-zeitliche Konzeption der
Geschichte, die meiner Meinung nach so aussieht, als
ob diese Kultivierung von Kultivierung
zu Moralisierung von
Moralisierung wir übergehen  weiter zur Zivilisation
und von der Zivilisation wir das Ich sagte, ich bin
nicht ins Detail gegangen Föderalisierung und noch
einmal, dies ist keine zeitliche Abfolge, also ist
es kein Seher, eine zeitliche Abfolge, es ist
eine idealisierte Sicht darauf, wie die Natur ist
Die vollständige Entwicklung der
natürlichen Anlagen über den Trieb zur
Gesellschaft zu bewältigen und diese dann auch in
einem nicht zeitlichen Sinne zu befolgen, diesen
vier Schritten zu folgen. Ich denke, das ist es, was
jemand hat
Artikel
von Quintett Sola Geben Sie politische
Anthropologie aus dem Land ein Buch
, das viel detaillierter ist und
ähnliche Punkte zu machen hat, wenn Sie
wirklich in viele weitere Referenzen einsteigen möchten,
können Sie sich diesem zuwenden,
damit Sie
jetzt aufhören können, ist dies nur reine
Spekulation
Ja, das ist übertrieben, da es
wirklich kompliziert ist und es einige Zeit dauert, bis
Sie 81 82 83 erreichen, und ich spreche nicht
von den folgenden Absätzen,
sondern nur von den wenigen Absätzen, die meiner
Meinung nach wirklich schwierig und herausfordernd sind und
Sie vielleicht denken  das ist etwas, das sich
sehr anhört, sieht aus wie ein
metaphysischer Roman, ja, ja, das
sagt Hegel, als wäre das Philosophie, es ist eine
Metapher, die man nach Hause zeigen kann, kann eigentlich nicht a
sagen  Ähnliche Dinge über das Leben,
lassen Sie uns wissen, also ist das nicht sehr
freundlich, ja, und das ist natürlich nicht
wahr,
es ist metaphysisch, aber es ist kein Roman, denke ich
, ja, ist das dieses
Modell des Strebens nach Gesellschaft, ein weiterer Roman in diesem
Sinne, ja, da ist etwas  ist
vorbei, verkompliziert die Dinge, es könnten noch viele
weitere Fragen gestellt werden, aber ich
denke, nein, vielleicht ist dies
in gewisser Weise keine angemessene Antwort, aber ich
denke, es lässt wirklich erahnen, was
noch kommen wird, und das ist das deutsche
idealistische Geschichtsverständnis  in
genau dieser entwicklungsweise
psychologischer fähigkeiten, die wir in
der vorinhaltsphilosophie sicher haben und
die uns einiges vorwerfen kann, versucht die [ __ ]
glaube ich zum ersten
mal ganz anders auszubuchstabieren
und das setzt sich dann im deutschen
idealismus fort  bedeutet, sich nicht nur
auf Gott zu beziehen und dann eine Liste zu erstellen
, in der Sie wissen, welche Arten von kognitiven Fähigkeiten
wir haben, vielleicht durch Selbstbeobachtung und
nicht durch Systemidentifikation und Systematisierung  Wenn wir sie jetzt betrachten, ist
dies wirklich ein Nachteil, der Ehrgeiz,
dies gezeigt zu haben, dass dies nicht
möglich ist, wir können nur
Verständnis und Sensibilität isolieren.  Das ist
es nur isoliert, wir können sie nicht reduzieren,
wenn dies eine akzeptable Ansicht ist, das ist eine
andere Geschichte, aber das ist völlig
anders als die Ansicht, dass Gott
diese Fähigkeiten in den menschlichen
Verstand eingepflanzt hat oder so, aber das ist wirklich etwas
zum Beschatten, das abgeschlossen ist, denke ich
oder abgeschlossen, wenn Sie denken,
dass dies das Ende ist, aber das wird
wirklich viel detaillierter ausgeführt und
atmen Sie den deutschen Idealismus ein, indem Sie das
Lesen und England beenden und etwas, von dem ich glaube, dass
ich die idealistische Geschichte des Selbstbewusstseins in Fester noch völlig zu wenig studiert habe
sicherlich so das frühe
Fischduschsystem des transzendentalen
Idealismus und Kant und Hegel Kant ist nicht der
ewige Idealist und Hegel die
Phänomenologie des Geistes, wo man
genau die Idee hat, in Feaster Erkenntnisvermögen,
in Schelling Erkenntnisvermögen
plus Natur und dann in
Inhalator die Wahrheit behauptet  Die Trittleiter der
Wahrheit behauptet, dass dieses wirkliche
Selbstbewusstsein den Bau oder den
Bautod vor der Wissenschaft datiert
Visionsschacht Ich bin mir absolut sicher, dass das
Gebäude dort irgendwie mit
der Tradition zusammenhängt, Gebäude zu kriechen, darunter zu
fahren, wenn Sie in den Text schauen, dann werden
Sie die Verwendung
dieser dieser dieser Begriffe wiederfinden,
danke